that being said um
i'm warming up to you still how long
it's been five years five years
five years i know five years with this
podcast i know
plus a maker time i know i know but
listen here this is
in this last year though right have i
not called you and texted you more
yes it's dropped off recently so i feel
like i feel like we're going a little
yeah yeah a valley right but in the last
year there's been more connection
between you and i
yes in terms of communicating
communicating yeah you're also different
this year what do you mean we've talked
about this you're different
how am i different you seem more
approachable
you seem oh i feel more approachable
more like he's willing to be friends
oh and he's also willing not to put a
shield up right away with us
specifically
yeah yeah yeah you know i'll tell you
what
you know i'll and you know that has a
lot to do with the pandy
right it has to do a lot of with um
realizing that we're on the same boat
and also i'm you know i got sober i went
to therapy this year my dad died there
was so many things that happened this
year
that made me a far more appreciative of
the people around me
and um but you know i at the end of the
day
i have to say congratulations to you i
can't look you in the eye right now but
um
wait i do let me finish oh sorry i'm
sorry i'm so sorry all right
i do love you
i do love you wow maybe look at the
camera so he'll yeah yeah he'll watch it
later
yeah cause he has to edit this i do love
you
and um i have fun feelings for you you
do irritate me
but that's how how
how could i irritate anybody i know i
know
okay you're right it's it's not
it has nothing to do with you right it
ha
i don't know what it is but um it just
takes me a while like for instance
you know there was this i'll just give
you an example it has to do with warzone
excuse me mm-hmm
but um there was this
[Laughter]
i don't know it's kind of like a cute
turtle
yeah that's really cute baby but um
there was this kid
i play with a married couple jacob
right and claire
and i forget their last name pablo or
something right
but jacob every day he would text me
not text me through instagram direct
message
ayan or i'm here
and for months i would ignore it every
day
and then one day i just decided i'll
play with him with him and his wife
and now they're one of my favorite
people to play with it just takes me a
while
to get people and you know it's just
taking you a while
but i i will always work with you
i would always like when joy santiago
reached out and said i'm thinking about
maybe doing a podcast
i the first name i say is maybe george
can help you he's a great producer
you know when the wayans brothers when
the wayne's brothers called me
and they said um you know
you know what because i'm doing a new
thing now where i don't want to do that
okay like urban boundary is never going
to come out again oh he's retired
[Laughter]
no but you know with this whole new um
society change and you know and with
cancer culture
and what we can and cannot do i'm still
learning it right so it's like
sometimes i'll sleep slip slip back into
urban body and then i'll catch myself
that's okay you know i mean i i think
that the reason that
bobby doesn't connect um deeply
or as enthusiastically with people who
are very reliable
and balanced and good is because
people like him and i what's familiar to
us is chaos
chaotic broken people that's what we're
attracted to because that's just what
we know and are familiar with like
throughout our lives right and with our
parents or our cousins like
so much dysfunction so i think what it
is is it's hard to connect with someone
so earnestly good and i think that's who
you are
you are so you've taught us so much
about just being
a [ __ ] good
reliable human being what are you
what do you what's that for keep talking
am i is that do you think that that
might be it that's exactly what it is
why are your lips
no matter how well i haven't said this
before no matter how annoyed i am well
whenever
i don't get a response for three days
about a simple question or anything else
there's nobody else i would want to work
with because i think
nobody's more entertaining i think i'm
drawn to the chaos even though i am the
opposite of it
and my response to anything is just uh
i don't like being told what to do so my
response is to be as do
things as perfect as possible and i see
other responses are to rebel
push buttons and anything else those are
like
that's what i wish i would do you know i
wish i could do
just push buttons rebel push buttons do
what exactly
it's not not in your nature if it's not
in your nature then it's not in your
nature
like and i also think that that's not
necessarily a good trait to have if no
it's in my fundamental it's in
everybody's fundamental nature